moi je crois que la droite ne se
reconstruira que si elle est rassemblée
qu'elle marche sur ses deux jambes je
les dis les libéraux et les
conservateurs également ses deux autres
jantes que sont le régalien et
l'économie c'est cette cesser ce à quoi
j'ai chanté son analyse compenser ce que
je m'efforcerai de la haye est de faire
au maximum de mes possibilités que
laurent wauquiez est capable justement
sur vos arguments là que vous venez de
rappeler marcher sur ses deux jambes
mais marcher sur ses deux jambes et de
redresser la droite
oui ou alors est ce que vous dites vous
que vous avez des doutes j aspire jeux
prince est la sienne dans son évolution
sinon nous aurons marine le pen ou
marion maréchal-le pen dont tout le
monde parle aujourd'hui est donc moi je
ne veux pas de cette porosité avec le
front national
je pense que nous avons un chemin il est
clair il n'est ni proche de macron ni
proche de le pen et c'est ce que je
m'évertuerai à mon niveau de continuer à
porter continué à porter mes convictions
et le fait que cette droite doit être
rassemblée je ne suis pas une diviseuse
j'ai entendu sa gelée lui pas du tout le
fait de dire que ce tract n'a pas été
validé par les instances c'est factuel
et c'est surtout que incertain de
fédérations du coup ne l'ont pas utilisé